symbolic annual event with powerful
images Earth Hour has been a moment for
millions of people to come together and
think about our impact in the world
around us
this year's event takes on new meaning
as billions take part in another shared
experience in light with all that is
happening with the coronavirus why not
turn this into a super special activity
with your household you can prepare a
candlelit dinner as it's at 8:30 and
evening switch off all electricity enjoy
each other's company and why not talk
about all the wonderful gifts that
Mother Nature has to offer and all the
things that we look forward to doing
once their isolation is lifted and we
can all be outdoors again and enjoy the
wonderful world we live in
let us learn the lesson that universe is
desperately trying to teach us at the
time that we're spending in isolation
not have been in vain in situations like
the one we're in at the moment we look
for silver linings and there is one in
terms of the climate and reduce levels
of pollution due to the corona virus
pandemic started breathing again and
it's a sure sign that we need to
reevaluate how we do things when things
go back to normal
satellite imagery from China has also
demonstrated that reduced human activity
is leading to reduced greenhouse gas
emissions something environmentalists
say is benefiting planet Earth a cities
and economies come to a halt while many
of our landmarks office buildings and
apartment blocks go dark for 60 minutes
seven point six billion people are being
forced by events or Mother Nature to
realize what else just isn't working
organizers say now more than ever is the
time to unite to safeguard our future
and the future of our planet
Andrew Chappell al-jazeera